let's hop into some updates with the
fall because i mean we saw a pretty good
market pullback and correction in the
summer time last time we when did we
talk last was it may or june
june yeah yeah so that was right around
the time that you know um we had elon
musk make his tweet and piss off a bunch
of people and there was some other
catalysts that made the entire market
correct and we saw 28 000 and change
bitcoin
all the altcoins pulled back
and
all the smart guys in your course you
know myself included made a whole bunch
of money scooping up the right one so
what happened and where are things going
and by the way guys um their course is
open again i'm gonna drop the link in
the youtube chat
uh let me just pin it up to the top and
it's also gonna be in the description
actually wait before you ask that
question i have another question for you
one of the things that drives me bonkers
on youtube is whenever we do a collab i
feel like i'm playing whack-a-mole for
like the next 24 hours deleting like
these fake spam comments from guys with
like whatsapp links hey it's rich cooper
or they use like a version of like my
channel name and they try to drive
people off to like scams and stuff how
do you get rid of that you can't so
this is me on my channel every day i
spend about 15 minutes a day cleaning up
my youtube
comment section which is you first thing
you can do is you can press report to
youtube right and then you do that just
pop up another account then they'll pop
up another account so i've gotten like
they may cultivate crypto and then they
have cultivate crypto with um loads on
it and then like um you know different
you know asterisks within there and
everything eventually then they run out
of it seems like they run out of options
and they change to something else um and
so then i get different ones but yeah
literally every day i'm just like yeah
it's whack hitting them i'm just going
to make it simple i'm just going to
disable cut like comments after the
video on this video so i don't really
deal with that nonsense anyway so um how
does every crypto video
yeah i don't know how you guys put up
with that it's just absurd we can't even
so there's so much that's what we also
tell people in the course how to uh
notice what scams are how to avoid them
how to i mean humans are usually the
weakest link right um people falling for
that type of stuff so yeah um you know
it seems obvious to a lot of people but
for some people i have met a few people
a handful of people who you know fall
for the uh send me one bitcoin i give
you two back uh scam you know they they
send a small amount first like five
hundred dollars they give you a thousand
dollars back and then you send ten
thousand dollars and they you never see
it again yeah we could do an entire
three hour episode on all the scams out
there but i mean if you understand basic
email phishing scams and stuff like that
then you should be smart enough to pick
up on them let's set that aside um so
what happened with the markets and
where where do you guys see things going
right now for the fall markets because
we're in september september 3rd right
now as we're casting this today
yeah there's a few different takes on it
um miguel do you want to go from from
your angle in in terms of what was
happening in june july
yeah basically basically it was sort of
uh
i would say it's more of a it was
coordinated attack in a way i'm trying
to fight us down um i i was more just
kind of like i was really taken back by
some of the influencers in the space how
every single major influencer on youtube
to twitter went pretty much negative on
crypto and then me and charlie were
pretty much the only people out here
saying that the only bulls left the only
bulls left
every bear is everywhere
but we were just saying that like this
market's not over there are so many
things happening
next year that it's not over like just
about every single exchange in north
america you know canada in the united
states is going public next year
gemini
kraken
uh ftx um ftx usa uh finance usa um
block fi celsius i mean just just any
company that's essentially can prove
they have some revenue and stuff they're
going public next year just off of that
you have enough firecrackers there to
push us well above six figures on btc
but in terms of what we expect this year
what we're expecting you know to crack
on over a hundred thousand dollars on
btc
in december in december yeah yeah and
then also to kind of add to that like um
there's one thing that we talked about
in the course that is still relatively
underground here in crypto there's a few
people that talk about it but really
only like one or two major people that
are discussing this which is on chain
data that's the data that you can look
at on the bitcoin blockchain like how
many wallets are there active that have
over a thousand bitcoin in them how many
wallets um you know are there in general
like how are they moving how long have
people been holding these uh wallets
like without spending their bitcoin and
stuff like this with all that data what
it basically tells you is
um the people with over a thousand
bitcoin the whales the the people who
have a lot of money in this market and
they're relatively
newer people to the space those people
plus the people who've been in crypto
for uh what we call like long-term
um both of those people from february um
through
april may were
not it's not a coordinated sell-off but
it was
like when they when you shear the sheep
without slaughtering the sheep right is
it consistent taking a profit before the
rest of the market and that's why when
you look at the chart like bitcoin is
going up then up a little bit less but
still up still new high but a little bit
less
right and then lost momentum and went
down and then when it did go down right
talking about june and july uh well may
june july basically there was an over
amount of um too much leverage in the
system basically too many people trading
on margin and so when you have that and
you get a flush out of margin um
basically the the one or two weeks of
red candles on bitcoin in may uh or mid
april and then with ethereum in may was
a flushing out of all that uh leveraged
trading i mean when you get the smart
money you get the people who are trading
a lot the whales right they tend to
leverage up because that's what they do
in the traditional markets as well and
so um
pushes up prices higher but also pushes
down prices higher so you get this kind
of like pretty intense whip saw effect
but then once that's done then you get a
time of intense accumulation you also
saw that on on chain data we talked
about that actually in our q3 course we
had a whole webinar of why the bull
market's not over based solely on on
chain data with our uh
with our friend plan c um and
that was a fantastic webinar he's gonna
do two more webinars in our next course
uh here for q4
what's up plan c
um he's a guy who talks heavily about
celsius as a as an exchange but then
also he joins us on moon gang from time
to time the show that we have on sunday
nights at 10 p.m eastern
and um so we'll be having that on this
sunday as well at 10 pm eastern people
want to come over to cultivate crypto on
youtube to watch that um super smart
dude he's basically a data analyst um
he's very driven by data and so he just
delves into the on-chain data and says
what kind of story can we find of what's
happening in the background based on
this so um you can look at the
fundamentals as miguel talked about you
can look at the technicals on the chart
like i talked about that you could look
at the on-chain data
there's another form of
analysis called chain analysis which you
can also use to look at different
transactions what's happening but you
put all these things together you get a
really good idea of what's actually
happening in the market which is much
more transparent than wall street right
with wall street they can play a lot
more tricks and do a lot more
underhanded deals in the background that
you'll never see in public maybe it gets
rumored but
people i mean people like with elizabeth
warren says you know we have shadowy
super quarters here in crypto and nobody
understands really what's happening here
you have so much you know dark web stuff
happening it's like bs um everything
here is the most transparent um yeah i
want to say another word you know
part of you know i don't don't want to
do that but um basically you know
everything is transparent it's on the
blockchain we can see exactly what's
happening and we can make good
guesstimations um
based on what we see happening on what
is actually going to happen in the
market future and what this is telling
us right now
is and john was saying this on his
channel right we have the infrastructure
bill coming out here for vote by
september 27th we also have if you look
at the charts a cycle low coming into
the mid-september those two
price events where the price comes down
a little bit is a fantastic dip
opportunity but you're going to get a
lot of people screaming bloody murder
saying oh my god this is a bull trap
we're going down to zero and that's the
best time to buy and so we're going to
be talking about that in the course
telling people you know how to be doing
this it's not financial advice it's just
our opinion um but you know we've been
doing this for a whole calendar year um
here this is our one year anniversary
the crypto mindset course we want to
make sure to take care of everybody here
in quarter four and give um as much
value as you can so 8.97 for this course
is an absolute steal like yeah it is a
steal and there was a lot of guys plus
yeah dude because there was a lot of
guys you know before i um
do all the updates and the thumbnail on
it because what i do is i create the
event that just pops up and i have to
make some updates and tick boxes to set
it up for the stream one of the things i
do is members only chat there's a bunch
of guys in the chat before you know i
updated they're all like this is awesome
i've made a ton of money like there was
at least four or five i should have
screenshotted them you know before i did
the update but like
i started looking at your material about
a year ago around the time that you guys
first launched the course and we've
talked before like i know that you know
you guys started casting this from
john's little shitty closet apartment
with like the blanket hanging off the
wall sharing the microphone
what was it that was like two dudes one
mic like what three or four years ago or
something like that
2019 february 13th was our first show
bitcoin was 3 600
yeah i feel like it was so long ago man
and it does feel like it yeah at that
time i was like
yeah you know i'm starting to come
around right and that's when i first
started the first guy that came on our
show that was willing to like stoop down
to the you know the level of us at the
time you know like
well in fairness like i started hearing
about this stuff back in 2012 and 13
when i was having lunch with my buddy uh
amir and he's like yeah i'm going all in
on the blockchain i'm like are you what
like what like are you crazy like
they're going to shut this thing down
and
it took me about i mean i was five or
six years you know behind him but
it took me a while to figure it out and
i mean the truth of the matter is the
vast majority of the population still is
not involved in the cryptocurrency
market i think it's like what is it like
something like one or two percent of the
world population has a wallet
yep and and also it does you're right it
is an extremely hard industry to find
good information on like we search
around youtube all the time that was the
whole point of us starting uh the tokyo
crypto show and then also my channel and
also tcc's channel um the whole point of
it is let's give the market real
unbiased information youtube's not going
to promote us uh in the algorithm we're
going to have a slow time gaining users
but we're going to you know basically
give people the real information what's
happening in the market so they can make
money and if that happens you can
actually give people real value um then
you know that's how we have the moon
gang so strong we have a lot of people
who have literally changed their lives
we have people considering um you know
giving up their corporate job and uh
renouncing their us citizenship uh if
they've done the course for about six
months to a year they're starting to
talk about those things they're like
hold your horses guys hold your horses a
little bit keep that cash flow going
we'll talk about multiple streams of
income in the course and stuff like that
but it's really awesome to see um you
know and a lot of people who come from
your community who've joined the course
um they pick up on it a lot quicker than
i think a lot of other people it usually
takes about people about four years um
to get up to speed in the cryptocurrency
space we do this within two weeks of the
webinars but then obviously you have
that's the first initial portion where
maybe somebody catches about 20 to 30
percent of the information that's in the
course and then we
say do that over spaced repetition you
know make a schedule for you to review
these webinars over the quarter or over
the next six months which i mean is how
people learn it's like learning a new
language and within six months you
basically can you know plug yourself
into the matrix of crypto enough to
understand um four to five years worth
of data and information that we're
giving you here and so that's a huge
speed uh you know like forward for most
people because if they try to do it on
their own they take in a lot of shitty
information um you know they're gonna
make mistakes regardless but at least
you know um we tell them how to limit
those mistakes as well
and uh they tend to do a lot better i
was talking with a kid who i think is in
his mid to late 20s
um
uh want to say too many details but i
just talked to him the other day he's
made four hundred thousand dollars this
year um just by taking the course he's
probably spent maybe
max two three thousand dollars on our
services
you